"The Batman" is finally here, and based on
fan reaction and critical consensus, it will
certainly stand the test of time as one of
the all-time great Dark Knight stories.
But some fans aren't amused by one major cameo.
Spoilers ahead!
Now that "The Batman" is out and people have
had time to marinate on it for a little while,
it's not above criticism.
No movie is perfect, and superhero fans have
never had any problem letting their feelings
be known when they believe a work of art can
do better.
And plenty of people have already taken to
Reddit to talk about that big cameo toward
the end of the film.
After Riddler is locked up in Arkham, he speaks
to his next-door cellmate.
This individual never reveals a name, and
in the credits, they're listed as "Unseen
Arkham Prisoner," but it's pretty obvious
who it's meant to be.
"You can call me 'Joker'!"
The unseen Arkham prisoner, played by Barry
Keoghan, references clowns and laughs maniacally
at the end of his speech.
In any other superhero movie, this would be
a tease that the Joker will be the villain
in the sequel.
But there are plenty of fans who believe the
sequel would be better suited with a different
antagonist.
One Redditor kickstarted a thread talking
about how there have been too many Jokers
as of late, saying,
"Batman has the most distinct and varied gallery
of villains and yet we are doing the Joker
again.
Barry Keoghan ([who] is great in anything)
is the third live action Joker in six years,
I wish we could get villains that weren't
properly explored in movies yet."
The Jokers he's referring to are Jared Leto
in "Suicide Squad" and "Zack Snyder's Justice
League," plus Joaquin Phoenix in "Joker."
It's a lot of the same, so to avoid people
burning out on Joker's shenanigans, some people
believe "The Batman 2" would be better off
exploring new characters.
Still, there are those who thought Keoghan
could have been someone else entirely, with
one fellow Redditor writing,
"According to the teaser website from the
post-credits scene it seems that Barry Keoghan
might actually be Hush."
Hush is an oft-ignored Batman rogue who's
actually Thomas Elliot, and he was hinted
at in the film itself.
When Bruce Wayne learns what his father did
to a reporter, we discover the reporter's
last name was Elliot.
Now, we know Barry Keoghan won't be Hush.
Director Matt Reeves has already shot that
idea down.
Reeves revealed that the unseen Arkham prisoner
is, in fact, the Joker, albeit a prototype
version who may not necessarily be fully formed
at this point.
It's possible Reeves just wanted audiences
to know that the Joker is in this universe,
but he may not inherently be the "big bad"
of the sequel.
In the follow-up, perhaps we'll get a version
of a deleted scene, which Reeves describes
like this:
"It's a scene where Batman is so unnerved
because the Riddler is writing to him.
And he's like, 'Well, why is this guy writing
to me?'
And he figures he's got to profile this killer.
He goes to see another killer that he's clearly
had an experience with in these first two
years."
The killer in question is the Joker, in a
scene that Reeves compares to "Silence of
the Lambs."
Could we see a scene like it play out in "The
Batman 2," where Bruce Wayne is at the end
of his rope with Hush, so he turns to another
madman to stop him?
Batman has an expansive rogues gallery, and
fans have speculated a future villain could
be anyone from Mr. Freeze to the Court of
Owls.
It's a big universe out there, and it's clear
the newest version of the Caped Crusader is
just getting started.
There are many directions a sequel could go
in, and for a subset of fans, they'd love
to see the road less traveled.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.